hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to condemned still
little drunk
alright top we're back in a dark
basement somewhere and fair what huh I
got a machine gun don't mess with me
I got aha 13 you're gonna get it now huh
is what I got hey what what oh yeah
that's not a fine good oh man like if it
not recording my video before I start
drinking oh oh you went down easy ain't
a man for mama she gon lose everybody
down here ah
ah well huh okay I'll go ow
Oh also as a slap as I punched my face
with my hand
ow oh great more down ha oh I forgot who
you were convenient okay jump down and
see if you can find your way back to the
stairs
one day I'll go back this way no you
jump it's not that far lady lady oh yeah
and we think of that look like high
kicks
oh yeah hey lady
no all right fine I'll catch you with my
big strong arms back to serious bit uh
yeah yeah yeah Wow who where why
Oh
I don't like who thought I saw something
oh good oh good wait what the hell who
the hell are you you have a shotgun how
many holes
seven I am not trained enough for two
shots of a shotgun no way well around
every freaking corner I'm out Oh No
dead bird I'm gonna get a Shaka hey I
got five and six that's so great for me
okay
give you that thank you - why is is up -
just cuz I sawed up doesn't mean it out
to be that kind of shotgun
let's keep shooting kind you know oh
that's intentionally Memphis keep
shooting I don't know
TV again
I don't like this this is really quiet
there's nothing happening yeah come on
yeah I can handle you guys I'm about to
die
Wow see you see you head no no stop huh
yes what no oh I got no helmet hey my
health is recuperating it's good right
that's good is that a police tell elbows
one shell why it's still quiet it's
still very quiet down here
I do like this pizza battle or it's a
piece of metal metal metal metal mel
metal matt matt dole met dole metal is
that metal metal where's the metal
there's the metal Hey I've almost got
all the collectibles for this level
that's good right that's good that's a
good thing you know one shotgun shell
what am I supposed to do wait am I going
in a circle I'm right ah
oh god you get it stop standing in a fog
like that it's real Thomas it took you
long I'll shut up lady gonna shotgun
your name on it also the bullets have
your names on it or Telus I don't know
what's that hi oh yeah you're fighting
justice you mind taking the lead through
this area oh come on Lady you're okay
going off on your own when you could
have been with me actually I ran into
all the months of surprised you didn't
come on Lisa
nope I'm not I'm not out I'm not out
eight years ago would put the kid and
the teacher at the same school in 1997
okay here it is
I've totally forgot what we were talking
about that guy good you gotta get
kidnapped again lady Anderson Carl I've
had a lot of Carl Anderson's but I bet
this is our guy he was enrolled or
sentenced to an educational
rehabilitation center but severely
terminal stop drinking st. Joseph's
secondary on North East 52nd and Fremont
it's been closed for five years and no
wonder
that's one of the worst parts of town
Christ the cops have just been letting
it go to hell three years good
you know what about the faculty it
doesn't list occupations just a list of
names huh
I'll take it back to the lab and see
what I can find what time you got back
to the lab where you belong
it's him he's been listening to us oh
don't make me go get him
it looks like we've attracted other
unwanted attention good more thoughts to
burger I'm a cop on the edge wait what
how did I get out here oh really
haha yeah paper cutter I'll take that
hey I see you Oh anybody else oh yeah oh
yeah ah don't make me use excessive
force oh yeah let me read you your
rights
the written on this paper cutter ah
Thomas the exit we need to make a run
for it I need to make a shut up for it
it's loaded wait no this is where we was
is where we were why do we go that far
around what about our serial killer no
one gives a crap the same information we
do so that means he's also gonna go to
the school perhaps I can catch two
killers with one now but isn't let her
kill the one video we had one on that
faculty list alright I missed a bird I
had two achievements an APB has been
issued by the local PD for FBI agent
Ethan Thomas who mysteriously
disappeared after his gun was used to
kill two local detectives even though
the names name has yet to be released to
the press local PD is taking that
situation very seriously and reportedly
will use force if necessary to bring the
alleged cop killer into custody
I kill no cops I kill a lot of thugs
Thomas its Malcolm how are you doing is
the ago luncheon doing well yes Thank
You Malcolm it's going as well as it can
be wait what are you doing here how did
you know where to find me not really
there uline's saw you from across the
street no he didn't he's in your mind go
crazy he's dead coincidence dead and I
know what your game is here Van Horn but
I've got a job to do if you'll excuse me
okay oh this looks fun an old abandoned
school Wow why is this not my favorite
thing ever oh wait no it's not oh that's
a big-ass rat crap desktop yes please
looks like a good weapon nothing in here
okay
that needs a sledgehammer Oh ladies that
door abled Oh nope nope oh it is not
gonna be fun is it this whole place is
not gonna be fun it's not gonna be fun
blood ah go it's Tasers powerful aah
paper cutter either desk which you write
paper on or you put paper on it and then
you write on that paper on the desk that
all my fave e and now I have a paper
cutter which is used to cut paper as
which to put under on desk I'm not
making a sense hey there's a
sledgehammer
Oh Oh all that desk are the desk stuff
mysteriously put back in place it's so
mysterious at Strout bah you just does
this no eyes is in a school there's not
safe for children
Hey hi hi damn it on fist
creepy ass crawly guy oh my god how are
you a lady ah Crawley guys so with your
bondage yeah ah hell oh I just oh I
thought that was like a big fat lady
something like that I don't know who let
this Bunsen burner on
so cooking in here ah goddamn it stop
startling me I don't deserve it
womp that's right you better run I got a
Taser all cooked up for you you ready
really are you ready oh I see it it's
your leg oh don't you kick whoops - hi
sorry hello hi no that's right
why don't I go in the men's restroom
first I always going the women's
restroom first
nothing grab the handrail ah I'll take
the sledgehammer any day and here ah
here we go whoa
nope shout gun shot gun shot gun two
shots
ball loose lips sink ships ah see the
timing just walk down starts I think
anyone right yeah of course good timing
unless you're in my head to school
those lips oh those are lips aren't they
human tissue color adipose deposits
Jason these are human lips and facial
skin Oh
so I run the faculty list a gym teacher
your location during Carl Anderson's
tenure was a man by the name of Samuel
yeah he sounds like an upstanding such
mask yes intense medical records
provided his facial tissue you're good
at all that collection alright moving
forward looking for a man with no lips
this should be fun oh do I fall through
here yep we oh wait I almost fell oops
yeah that was pathetic
finish yeah random balls I hope that
hurt a lot anybody else what this would
be wait a minute wait isn't it no no
that's not the same I'm good for
yourself by either way I'm all out of
time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always
we'll see you in the next part bye-bye